how do i start how do i get into this
social media game how do i put out my
stuff very simply step one the manifesto
first you gotta figure out what or why
you wanna talk about it for me legacy of
being an entrepreneur or giving advice
and then number two you've gotta figure
out where you're gonna deploy your first
piece of manifesto content this rant
this mission statement there's only
really three core ways in the current
internet to really communicate to the
world the written word or video what i'm
doing right now am i talking it's
screwing you up i love it um audio and
then finally distribution if it's
written word you look at the mediums the
linkedin the wordpresses you start a
blog if it's video you've got youtube
facebook you've got instagram if it's
audio you've got soundcloud sketcher
google voice itunes you've got to get
distribution the way you do that is
either through time or money money's
easy facebook ads google ads time is
hard but if you have no money it's your
only option if you want people to know
about your stuff you need to find other
places that have eyeballs or ears and
get it out there that's how you start